session here with Michael blankton
um I asked him how I should introduce
him today he said he's a tree climber
um he has done a lot of stuff so that
describes him but I let him introduce
himself a little bit more if he wants to
but he will talk about today uh unit
style networks for time series future
identification
thank you
um I'm Michael Byington I'm working for
a small startup company doing pipeline
inspections not pipelines like data
pipelines but pipelines is in physical
oil and gas pipelines
the things that I've done with neural
networks in this job are things that are
quite literally only interesting to me
and to absolutely zero other people but
because neural networks generalize to
many many different problems I'm hoping
that I can kind of outline a case study
of ways to think about problems that do
not neatly fit into
computer vision natural language
processing and the things that you
immediately think of when you think of
neural networks
um to get started I want to tell you a
little bit about the the context of the
problem so the pipelines that carry
fluids uh that you think of long
distance transport pipelines uh came
into existence in the United States in
the 1860s they were the primary
competitive advantage of a company
called Standard Oil which made the
Rockefeller Fortune uh John D
rockefeller's arguably the richest
American that's ever existed and that
was largely because of Pipelines
from the 1860s to the 1960s the strategy
was
if it leaks there's a problem if not
ignore it there wasn't really any
alternative in 1964 I believe it was a
company called Tuboscope
created a magnetics flux leakage device
which used a lot of magnets and you
would stick this device inside the
pipeline push it with fluid and it would
record data and from that data you would
try to infer things about the quality of
the pipeline and hopefully fix
problems in the pipeline before they
resulted in environmental disasters
this is essentially the technology
that's in use today primarily the main
problems with these is they are
enormously expensive to run an MFL tool
through your pipeline you're looking at
minimum hundred thousand dollars per
survey for a high quality survey you're
looking at you know one to ten million
dollars just to do the inspection that's
not to fix anything that's wrong that's
just to get data on the pipeline
and if you talk to pipeline operators
you will discover that these things
don't work very well they very often
report that the pipeline is in pristine
condition only to have it fail a week
later or that the pipeline is horribly
corroded and must be replaced you go dig
it up and you find pristine pieces of
pipe uh it's not 100 but it awful like
that but in extreme cases these things
fail quite rapidly the other big problem
these have is there's a hundred years of
pipelines that were installed
with no thought that you might want to
stick one of these in the pipeline so
this thing cannot go around it bends
diameter changes
valves with bore sizes that are smaller
than the existing pipe and so there's a
giant collection of pipelines that are
known as unpigable lines these things
are colloquial colloquially known as
pigs so in the 2010s we started trying
to invent devices that could get us at
least some data on unpickable lines
the picture on the upper right is the
device that the startup company that I
work for Champions it's called a piper
and it's a free-floating little tennis
ball size device that you soft to a
pipeline operator so our people are
never on site they drop it down their
pipeline they ship it back to us we read
the data off a USB stick and then we try
to analyze it and tell them something
useful about their pipeline that's our
business model
um
we've got a number of sensors on board
this device and
the easiest use case there are several
use cases for this device but the
easiest one to understand is you have a
leak in your pipeline we go floating
past the leak and we can hear it it
sounds like you know water gushing out
of a hose if the leak is large
there's a whole bunch of cases in which
we might not be able to hear a leak but
in the cases where we can hear a leak
it's
pretty unambiguous that that's what's
going on there's not a lot of other
noises in the line that you might
confuse with the leak the problem here
is we know when we passed by the leak
but that does not tell you where the
leak is we know when the survey started
and ended we know the length of the
pipeline but if you just use start and
end and interpolate between you're going
to get a horrible time to design
conversion because pipeline operators do
not operate pipelines at constant flow
rates or constant pressures or constant
any things it is all a disaster
we use as much information as they'll
give us Ben's any metallic Hardware that
we can see in the magnetics data
diameter changes which we can see by
changing velocity elevation changes
which we can map to changes in the
pressure data that we collect so the the
time to distance mapping is complicated
but what's important to understand is
that we need to identify all the Joint
locations in order to get an accurate
distance because
for the most part they're going to work
with regularly length pieces of pipe and
those regular sized pieces of pipe if we
can identify Joint locations we can get
a much more accurate distance than we
can by any other method
the other problem is joint
identification is very manual and very
expensive and this is what I was hired
to solve two years ago
this is a very short piece of pipe this
is probably
somewhere between
800 and
2800 kilometers I would guess this whole
survey took like 25 minutes
and this is just the magnetic flux
inside the pipe our devices don't have
any magnets in them we're not applying
any electric fields or magnetic fields
this is just what you measure if you
drop a magnetometer down an oil pipeline
um
the reason this is hard to do is because
some joints are pretty obvious right I'm
sure that nobody here thinks you need a
neural network to identify these joints
you could write it just sci-fi find
Peaks and you could get a perfect
location for all of these Peaks
but joints are
heterogeneous if you look at pipeline
magnetics data enough it starts to look
more like image detection I know when I
see it I'm looking for a pattern that's
relatively regularly spaced but I don't
exactly know what that pattern is going
to be sometimes it spikes sometimes it's
increases in the oscillation frequencies
sometimes it's sudden offsets
there's a million different things that
a joint could be but we know that the
joint is the only thing that's going to
show up that frequently and that
regularly spaced an interval in the
pipeline
so this is where I got hired to try to
design a neural network that would pick
these things out so how many people here
here are familiar with neural networks
oh that's most of you okay sorry I might
have a little more information than you
need
how many people here don't get invited
to parties because they design overly
complicated architectures and nobody
else wants to hear about them
okay so that's a couple of us we're
going to be friends
I'm going to run through
neural networks 101 in a couple slides
hopefully I don't bore anyone too much
neural networks are really simple uh
nobody is too intimidated by them uh
basically when someone says fully
connected layer you just think matrix
multiplication someone says
convolutional layer just think that's a
convolution operation from mathematics
there's nothing complicated or special
about it and a pooling layer is a
traveling window that's taking the max
or the average or the Min or some other
simple uh operation in practice it's
always the max just assume a pooling
layer is a Max pool layer if someone's
doing something that's different than
that it's their obligation to tell you
that they're being weird and why they're
being weird
when you draw out a neural network
graphs the red dots represent numbers on
the left side that's your input on the
right side that's your output in the
middle those are the hidden layers that
you generate you have a weight that
connects each input layer to each
sequential layer and if you draw this
out in a graph you have drawn out a
series of Weights that are well captured
by a matrix you multiply W1 by Vector
one you get uh
or you get Vector two W2 X2 gives you X3
et cetera et cetera now for those of you
who have paid attention during uh your
algebra class you might notice that all
of these matrices they collapse and you
don't actually need that many numbers
this is something of a problem in
designing neural networks but it's a
problem that's really easily solved this
is why we have activation functions you
apply a function to each
a scalar in the hidden layer hidden and
as long as that function is non-linear
and differentiable everything is fine in
practice you want the simplest possible
activation function because it will make
it computationally easy to compute if
you want to get more performance out of
your network you're going to get much
more bang for your buck by changing the
size of the layers the orientation of
the layers the number of layers if you
spend time trying to change activation
functions around it's very unlikely that
that's going to improve the performance
of your network relative to doing these
other things
simplest thing that you can compute is a
relu and that's why almost all modern
networks use relu activation functions
there are some exceptions but in general
that's how it's done
convolution it's a lot easier to explain
the convolution by stealing a graphic
from Wikipedia than it is for me to talk
about it verbally it's a traveling uh
frame that gets multiplied and sumps
across a subset of your data and then it
moves across the entire
um
the the incred the entire input to
generate the output the nice thing about
convolutions is they allow you to learn
about features of your data independent
of where they occur in your data and
they're comp they're a computational
imputation way to connect large layers
together if you were to do this with a
fully connected layer instead of having
nine weights you'd have close to 1300 so
this is an excellent way to learn things
independent of where they can do occur
within a homogeneous data set
uh convolutional neural networks are the
go-to standard for almost all computer
vision tasks at this point
so if you were going to design a neural
network that identified happy frogs from
sad frogs you would take all the pixels
in your neural network
this is probably a bad neural network to
do this because this is pictured as
fully connected layers you'd probably
want to do this with convolutions
you have a whole bunch of Weights in
this neural network
you have to Define some way of
telling the neural network how well it
did at deciding whether that was a Happy
Frog or a sad frog you do this with
what's called a loss function the only
thing that's important about a loss
function is that it's differentiable and
when it goes down that's good
other than that you can Define any loss
function you want in practice it's very
difficult to Define new loss functions
that are useful so when you're doing a
classification task like this
cross-entropy loss is the go-to standard
um
it is beyond the scope on the talk but
you're just gonna have to take my word
for it that it is possible to
computationally fairly efficiently
compute the derivative of the loss
function with respect to every single
weight in this graph and then it is
possible to update every single weight
in this graph by moving every single
weight a very small distance in the
direction that lowers the loss function
for the given collection of input data
so in order to build a neural network
you start by just defining your graph
randomly choosing some weights to start
with these are there's a little bit more
to it in the sense that if your
distribution of Weights doesn't conform
to certain things or certain constraints
then you might get something that never
converges but most neural network
libraries do that for you automatically
so you don't have to worry about it it's
it's randomly chosen to start with for
our purposes here you select a small
subset of your data you can augment that
data stretch or compress or do something
that changes it slightly so that the
neural network can't memorize it
and then compute the loss function over
the small subset of data
update all the weights wait and when you
go through this process this is called
training your neural network
um the cool thing about deep learning is
the first step is almost always remove
almost all the contacts from your
problem
this is nice because once you've solved
the problem
you've solved many many problems and
then you have cause to celebrate
so unet is a neural network
that came out in 2015 that
revolutionized a collection of problems
called segmentation problems and it was
designed to do this which is to say
taking a micrograph of cells pick out
all of the pixels in that micrograph
that are cells
we're going to do the same thing we have
the XYZ components and so we have a
one-dimensional
image
and we are going to identify all of the
joints in our one-dimensional image
this is the analogy
that I'm trying to stress uh because I
think this is the most critical part of
my talk
if you can see an analogy between these
two things you can use the very powerful
solution that was published in 2015 to
solve this problem
that nobody else cares about and
it's very useful if you're working for a
startup company and you're the hired to
be the only for the own the world who
cares about this thing
um unfortunately there's a couple small
complications
if you take this network as it's written
and you convert all the convo all the
two-dimensional convolutions to
one-dimensional convolutions
nothing works the network doesn't train
um and the reason it doesn't train is
because there's a concept in
convolutional neural networks called a
receptive field when you have fully
connected layers this doesn't apply but
because the convolutions are only
looking at a small subset of the data
between each layer when you stack layers
on top of each other
the the final node is only being
influenced by a subset of the input
pixels
the authors of this paper gave us a very
convenient
equation for a collection of
convolutional and pooling layers to
Define how large this receptive field is
and when you apply this to unet and
we're just looking at the encoder side
which is the left hand side of the
network I wasn't quite sure how you
would interpret that on the transpose
convolutional layers going up the decode
to decide but if you're just looking at
the encoder side you're looking at a
receptive field of 140 by 140 pixels
for inputs that are 500 something by 500
something pixels you're looking at a
third of the image that's more than
enough context for unit to figure out if
something is a cell or not a cell
unfortunately if you just change the
two-dimensional Evolutions to
one-dimensional convolutions you still
only have a receptive field of 140
pixels
140 pixels
is not enough context to make a decision
about that point as to whether that is a
joint or not
um
but because that equation gives us a way
to change that if you just increase the
strides and the kernels of the
convolutional and pooling layers you can
very rapidly in increase that context
and I designed something that got that
context up to over 10 000 pixels
and that is enough context to determine
whether each of those points is a joint
or not a joint because you can see
several joints in that context you can
find periodic features so that's the
that's the key to making all of this
work
uh data augmentation is critical when
you're working with small data sets we
do not have access to the kind of data
that you have at Google or Facebook we
have very small data sets this can all
all of the training data can fit in the
RAM on my desktop so we're trying to get
as much out of it as we can
in order to do that we're trying to
change the data in ways that
don't affect the features that we're
looking for but prevent the neural
network from memorizing specific
features of our input data
in this case we can compress or stretch
the data in the X Direction which would
correspond to our devices moving faster
or slower through the pipe there's no
particular reason they had to move at
the speed that they went through the
pipe we can compress or stretch our data
in the y direction if the magnetic field
was slightly more powerful in the fight
we would just as easily be able to
recognize the joints so this stretching
and compressing doesn't change anything
and then we can take the mirror image of
our data
um because that would correspond to just
traveling through the pipe in the
reverse Direction
what
was 12.6 million weights
um 111 surveys that contain 91 000
labeled joints but because of the data
augmentation we were able to show this
network 40 million labeled joints in
training and it never once saw the same
joint twice
there was always some augmentation
applied to it and because those
augmentations can vary in magnitude it's
very easy to get essentially an infinite
number of training examples that doesn't
mean you have infinite power but it does
give enough variability that this will
learn incredibly powerfully and
generally generalize extremely well
the end result is that if you feed this
piece of data into the neural network
you'll get y1 and Y2 which is the no
joint and Joint labels in this fashion
if you take a soft Max of that which is
just this equation right up here you get
spikes at all of the joints and this you
can always run a peak Search tool on and
recover a joint list so that
I think that's pretty cool now that is
an example of how to apply this
to something nobody here cares about but
uh it did really well
there's a number of ways to take to tang
and make it more General
and apply it to a broader category of
problems for example
sometimes we run attached to the back of
a cleaning Pig
the acceleration gyroscope might give
you some information if the cleaning Pig
fits tightly that piece of rubber will
hit the joints and you can integrate
this information and find a whole new
neural network that works in the same
way as the old one but is much more
accurate for pig runs
transfer learning works on these
extremely well if you freeze the first
or and last couple of layers
and then train for a few thousand Cycles
you get wonderful results
Cardiology in one slide I'm looking for
examples of things that other people
might care about
and I was trying to come up with ways
that I could apply this network transfer
learning on this network to something
that was more broadly interesting it
should work on anything that you are
doing that involves one dimensional time
series data for which you have a lot of
labeled data of the things that you want
to identify
um in cardiology this is a heart I hope
everyone uh has one
um
uh hearts are a little more complicated
than I realized but you have these two
Chambers up top uh that do a little
squeeze to fill the two Chambers at the
bottom and the two Chambers at the
bottom push the blood out the one on the
right shoves blood just into your lungs
the one on the left shoves it into the
rest of your body
there's a electrical system in your
heart that control controls contract the
top contract the bottom sequence
basically you have a pacemaker that's
your SA node the electrical signal
travels across the Atria your atrial
contract about a tenth of a second later
after a delay in the AV node your
ventricles contract and push the blood
on
this is how cardiologists try to figure
out what's wrong with your heart they
stick a whole bunch of electrodes across
your body and they measure the
electrical signals that come through
this sequence of
fibers
I'm not a doctor please do not hire me
to be your cardiologist
um
what you end up with is uh depending on
which one of these you're looking at you
should be able to see most of these
features in most of these different
combinations of electrodes a P wave
which is the contraction of the Atria
the top Chambers the QRS complex which
is the contraction of the ventricles
which are the bottom Chambers and the T
wave way corresponds to the
repolarization of the ventricles
the Atria obviously polarized but
they're much smaller and they do so at
almost the same time as the QRS complex
so you can't see the repolarization of
the Atria typically in an EKG signal
I downloaded a bunch of EKG data and I
applied this transfer learning to learn
using the neural network that I trained
on Pipeline magnets magnetics data
and this is my one and only test or
validation set
but I'm pretty proud of it like it
it found all the p waves the qas
et cetera et cetera I'm not going to say
that this is the best data science
anyone's ever done but I am going to say
that it's a really interesting proof of
concept and that this does generalize to
much more than pipeline magnetics and
that's why you should take me seriously
um
I did this by taking my neural network I
froze everything but the first and last
layer I I had maybe 400 of these that I
labeled manually so very very small very
set
trained it for about about a thousand
training Cycles uh using all the same
data augmentations as the uh
pipeline data except for the mirror
image because your heart doesn't pump
backwards I hope
um
if you do that for a thousand training
Cycles this way and then you unfreeze
sorry and then you unfreeze the the
middle of the networking train for
another thousand Cycles you can recover
this result doesn't take very long
um the longest part of this was manually
labeling 400 EKG signals
it was raining on Saturday I didn't have
anything better to do
um
I I really like data I collaborate with
a lot of different people so for reasons
that I will explain off camera if
anyone's curious I have an enormous
amount of data of asphalt deflecting
um on a variety of conditions when heavy
things roll over it
foreign
you might be curious about where the
rebounds in that uh data occur because
rebounds and asphalt have a lot to do
about failure modes of asphalt
again same procedure I took my neural
network I froze all but the first and
last layer and trained it for a
thousand-ish Cycles uh repeated the
training with the network unfrozen for
another thousand cycles and I was able
to identify all the rebounds in all of
the test cases that I use
the only thing that's tricky about this
that you would want to keep in mind if
you were trying to reproduce this
yourself
is that the neural network is learning
about
Peaks and valleys and spacing based on
the spacing between data points that's
its sense of time so if you don't up
sample your data so that the Peaks are
spaced in time by approximately as the
same number of data points the transfer
learning fails completely
the inputs that we were shoving into
this neural network
our 81 000 data points long the EKG data
was
three thousand four thousand data points
so that had to be significantly
upsampled in order for that to work the
same is true with the airport or the
runway deflection data
didn't work very well when I tried to do
it with earthquakes the main reason
being that earthquakes are are I believe
the main reason is that earthquakes are
kind of a broad signal
um they're
they're not discrete points that you're
trying to identify and as such transfer
learning pretty well failed I also only
had a couple hundred uh labeled samples
of these micro earthquakes that I was
trying to apply this to so I gave up I
got
a little demoralized there but if you
had a lot more of this earthquake data
I'm very positive that you could make a
neural network that identified your
micro earthquakes by training it from
scratch
um
I think there's a lot of cool stuff to
learn here but what I'm hoping that
you'll take away is that you can use
neural networks to do more than just uh
image detection natural language
processing and all the traditional
things if you're able to see
analogies between different types of
problems you can apply the solutions
that are out there to
very very unusual applications
and with that I will open the floor for
questions
if you don't want to ask my questions in
front of everybody you're welcome to ask
me privately I love talking about neural
networks so I hope that I am not
intimidating in any way
thank you
thank you for the talk
um welcome very naively per your premise
um my first thought with these like
these these tennis balls is well um is
there there must be some constraint
that's preventing you from getting like
geolocation data attached to these and
I'm curious what that constraint is
because uh yes there there's there's a
number
um the first one is we struggle with
battery life in these devices uh the
second one is you're you're in a steel
tube you're in a faraday cage that makes
it really tricky uh forth you're
underground in most cases like we run
subsea lines that are thousands of
meters below the surface
um and all of that combines to
it's really hard to get location data
there are situations where we get a
little bit more location data via kind
of unconventional means you wouldn't
think about
um and these are
collectively known as above ground
markers so they'll stick giant magnets
on the side of the pipe or or just above
the pipe and they'll hope that you can
see that signal or they'll stick little
woodpeckers on the side of the pipe and
so it's just a metal device that's
tapping on the pipe and you'll hear it
as you go by and it gives you a location
you know at that time you were at that
spot
um
the market that we're going after are
places where you can't use any of that
stuff and there's all kinds of reasons
that you can't use any of that stuff
I mean there's expense with installing
it there's we run in areas of the world
where it's not safe to install it where
you're
you can't send people into the
area because there's
Wars and instability and places where
you just really don't want personnel
there for liability reasons
all of that means that we're trying to
do it with the least amount of
information we can
um
hi uh thank you for the talk um
so I'm not like a neural network expert
by any stretch of the imagination but
then you might have enjoyed the slides
yeah
um
I guess can you just talk a little bit
about like what you mean when you say
you like freeze a couple layers with the
transfer learning and and things like
that and just I because I I'm not as
familiar with transfer learning I
understand reinforcement learning a
little bit but okay yes yes
um when you are doing transfer learning
you don't have to do this transfer
learning just means you take an existing
collection of weights with an existing
architecture and you're going to try to
apply it to a new problem
um you're going to do the same thing
where you've got a loss function you're
going to give it some training data and
then you're going to update weights then
you're going to give us some training
data and you're going to update weights
when we say freeze the network we're
just not going to bother updating any of
the weights in the layers that I've
grayed out here you're only updating
weights in the first and the last layer
or the first and last couple layers
that makes the transfer learning work
better you get much higher performance
out of that because initially the
derivative is going to tell you to
change all sorts of things throughout
the entire network
and if you're trying to move in a very
different space it's
intuitively it makes sense that you
would want to change the input to look
more like what the neural network was
originally trained on and so if you do
this freezing where you're doing several
training Cycles without updating any of
the weights in the center of the network
you get better results
so that's what I mean when I say freeze
layers of the network thank you also
just out of curiosity what's the like
length of a how long can some of the
pipelines be oh uh the longest pipeline
we've run I think is on the
I know we've done pipelines that are
over 100 kilometers I don't know
if we've gone over 120. uh generally
we're moving at about
one meter per second or so and we've got
a 24 hour run time so that gives you
kind of an upper bound on what we can do
hi thanks for the talk
um I I work with uh with ppg's signals
as part of the sort of domain which are
similar to EKGs in the sense that they
can represent a heartbeat event uh so
much about Cardiology like I made that
up I I don't know that much either uh
but yeah so I have no idea what you're
measuring just to be clear it's an
arterial artificial wave but it's like
uh you know you get a you get a
something that's it and it get there
they have common use cases that um would
be synonymous with EKGs there's some
overlap in the science surrounding them
but anyway what my question was um
drawing on your experience using this
network for event detection in in the
pipelines
um
how was the performance were there any
issues you ran into with noise because
that's really the problem with event
detection and ppgs if you have a clean
signal it's really actually quite easy
to get event detection but the thing is
it's like you never have a clean signal
and so I'm curious if you could comment
on that
um yeah so we we've got very
large amounts of heterogeneity among
what these signals look like and some of
them
we can't see welds that we we
occasionally get pipelines probably
five percent of the pipelines that come
in we open up the magnetics and we're
going to manually identify welds and
we just don't know what to do we don't
know what we're looking at
um my experience has been that anything
that we can manually identify so we know
that there is a feature there that we
can manually detect we can train a
neural network to do it if we've got at
least
150 000 labeled examples of what we're
looking for
getting those labeled as examples is the
hard part and it's and it's not clear
whether the human eye can't see it or
the information is just not in the
magnetic so you can imagine
it's possible that
in some of these pipelines it's not
there
but there's no amount of noise that we
have had that we've been unable to see
through with a neural network if you can
manually see through it with your
eyeball
I don't know that there's any
fundamental reason for that the easy one
to come up with is at some point the
just the information is not in your data
uh but we haven't proven that the
information is not in our data we've
just proven that we haven't been able to
detect anything else I'm not sure if
I've fully answered your question but I
tried
if you could fully answer my question
I've got a job proposition
we have maybe time for one more
and while you're getting over there we
are always hiring just Shameless plug if
anybody really wants to play with
pipelines cool uh thank you for the talk
it was great
um is there any sort of analogy to like
the Shannon Nyquist theorem that ties
like the window length that you're
looking at that the neural network is
capable of seeing to like what scale of
feature you can you can detect
um
so it depends on how much
I guess the question is how much context
do you need to see the feature and
that's going to be very feature
dependent so
that I
that's going to be very application
dependent in our case if you zoom in
what you're looking at your manual
labeler can't identify a joint if if he
or she is looking at less than one spool
spool is a single
manufactured piece of pipe less than one
spool of data it's very it's Intel
because a lot of what you're looking for
is a repeating structure
if we don't give the neural network the
context of that repeating structure
performance drops very significantly
I don't know if there's anything about
that that can generalize to other
applications because I can imagine that
a cardiologist does not need to see
multiple heartbeats to recognize a QRS
wave and therefore I would assume that a
neural network does not need to see
multiple heart rates to identify a QRS
wave
I think there you're looking at
something that's much more application
dependent than any answer that any
simple answer that I could give you cool
thank you
okay thank you very much you've heard of
questions feel free to such places very
sociable you can talk to me anywhere
thank you
foreign